we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we are going to go next to our caller
from the 3 0 9 area code caller from 3 0
9 please introduce yourself hey 3c 3 0 9
you're on the air we can hear the
background noise I don't know if you can
hear me what do you think they're doing
right now maybe it's a butt-dial you
think so they've accidentally dialed the
David Pakman show right when we're
taking calls that's weird 3:09 are you
there I'm here
are we on speakerphone right now I'm
walk what we do it please take us off
speakerphone and go right ahead with
your question okay
sounds the same so far go ahead with
your question I am on right you're live
on the air yes but your time is quickly
elapsing unless we can get to a question
maybe ok so my question was that since
I've heard a lot of people argue that
the u.s. becoming isolationist would
make it easier to run you know
rebuilding infrastructure health care
and college and that sort of thing every
summer people countered but it would
make the u.s. more vulnerable in the
case of attack but I never really
thought that made a lot of sense because
us on ice away from this and not
involved in all the wars and such were
involved in now there will be far less
we've been for us to get attacked you
think that makes sense
I don't think that we'll listen I'm not
an advocate of a totally isolationist
policy I think the US can't be the
policemen of the world I think we do
need to limit our use of the military
around the world and I actually do think
that on the net adopting that type of
policy would reduce the risk to the
United States rather than increase it
but I have
to ask what are you doing like me what's
the noise we're hearing in the
background are you watching another show
while you're on the phone with us or are
you doing some kind of cutlery
sharpening or like what what are you
doing Walker and my mom's cutting
vegetables and you know no honey what
vegetables is she cutting um she's
cutting carrots and onions okay
what she man peppers is she making a
particular dish you I haven't had before
oh okay all right listen I can't do any
more of it I appreciate the call that
we're gonna have to end it I tried to
stick with it as long as I could but it
was getting it was getting pretty tough
there was a surprisingly a nuanced and
eloquently asked question it I wasn't
expecting that question based on the
first 45 seconds of the call that's for
sure